[Music]
hey guys it's Jan I here let's work on
getting sculpted in the thighs legs and
bum today so start by Jing on the spot
to get your legs warmed up what we'll be
doing are five different exercises and
trust me you will feel the burn because
that's what we want in order to Target
the trouble spots okay your goal is to
complete 10 repetitions per workout good
keep jugging bring your heart rate up
and now let's get into squats and this
is your part of our warmup if you like
my workout CS today they are by Ali you
can go on to their website and key in
the promo code J so 20 to get 20%
discount of your first
order I'm getting out of breath and they
make your legs and butt look really good
keep squatting good now just shake it
out
the first workout will be lunch forward
and backward so start in a straight
position let's take a wide step forward
and go all the way back and lunch back
okay so let's do 10 one good back two
nice wide step back wi step forward
three make sure you're lunging
deep four only work on one side good
five keep your body straight six
six up seven lunge you should you should
feel the burn on both legs eight last
two more
nine one more
10 good and stay right here and now what
I want you to do is to get into P your
lunges so small 10 jumps ready let's go
1 2 3 4 5 6 78 8 9 10 wo did you feel
the burn that's your first workout now
same thing on the other side so step
with your right leg and let's bring your
left leg forward go one lunge wide back
good two keep
going three catch your
breath bance Yourself four look straight
ahead
five good
six four more guys seven this will
really work on your legs eight you
should really feel the burn on your
hamstrings and your qus nine one more
and now back hold it let's get straight
into 10 PES one 2 3 four holy five 6 7 8
9 10 good job Shake It Out second
workout sumo squat this will work on
your inner thighs so take a wide step
toes pointed out as wide as you can
without having your knees go over your
toes okay so stand in a comfortable
position and let's go 10 sumo squats one
push your butt back
two three just place your arms in front
four five six you should feel this part
seven
9 10 now stay low bring your toes up
let's bring your heels down and up this
is really to kill your inner thigh let's
do turn one if you feel leg shaking
that's normal two down and up
three
four
5 6 wo
nine 10 oh my god do you feel your inner
thighs and your legs shaking well done
and the next workout jump squats so
let's aend to make three small pulses
and jump it up okay let's do 10 ready go
one two three up good one two three
reach as high as you can one two three
up good 2 three four up 2 three five up
2 three six four more one 2 3 seven look
straight
ahead eight last two
more
9 10 well done so that was set one now
we're going to repeat two more sets okay
and so catch your breath drink some
water if you need to and we're going to
start from the beginning
ready catch your breath first workout
lunge forward and backwards okay let's
go right side
one good two as wi as you can
three nice
four sweating
five
eight good last two
9 10 and stay back and let's get
straight into temp PES 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 Shake It Out left side okay let's go
forward
one good two keep going I know your legs
are burning
three
[Music]
four five when you hurts keep pushing
six it's a good burn
seven eight come on two
more
nine last one
10 and stay back let's go one 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 and shake it out right straight
into sumo squats I'm already stretching
halfway through let's go wi stuns okay
place your arms in front if you want to
or by your wings go one up
two three butt back feel inner thighs
four
6 7 good eight eight if this is too easy
9 10 LIF a dumbbell okay toes stay low
let's go up and down good one feel your
legs checking two
three
4 5 point it six seven stay low eight 9
10 and Shake It Out jump squat ready
three pulses and jump it up let's
go one two three go one two three up low
two three up two two three up four two
three four good keep
going five five more push your butt
back keep going three more one 2 3 back
straight one 2 three up one more one 1 2
3 woo and well done all right catch your
breath if you feel like you're
completely out of breath and you need to
stop while take a short breather and get
back into the workout when you're ready
okay let's stay strong and do the final
set together set number three I'm
absolutely dripping but remember we do
not stop when we're tired we stop when
we're done
okay let's go lunge forward and back
ready let's go one good two count with
me keep going three strong line strong
body four
lunge five all the way back good
six seven very good this is your last
set eight bance your Cor tighten your
core nine tighten your core 10 stay back
10 PES go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 woo done
another leg ready let's go forward one
push it back
two back be sure to take a wide step
three back
I'm losing my balance
four
back
five oh my
God six keep
going gain your strength back
seven
[Music]
9 last one
10 stay low 10 PES 1 2 3 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 good job your lunges are done let's
get straight into sumo squats wipe your
sweat or look
sexy okay wide step toes points out
inner thighs ready down and up push your
butt back two up slow down three up slow
four Slow Five slow six 6
8 9 one more 10 good now stay low toes
up let's go 10 one really cill those
inner thighs two three scop them four
hold it five Shake six 7 8 9 10 oh my
God oh my God Shake It Out only small
movements will give give you effective
results final stack final workout squat
jumps right full energy let's go pulse
three times jump and reach up ready one
2 3 up two 2 three up
good imagine you're a basketball player
four
reach five come on ladies and guys
six
seven three
more eight you're doing very
well nine last
one
10 amazing amazing job well done grab
yourself the glass of water and take a
breather and rest you know what it feels
like it feels like I've just showered in
sweat so if you're sweating like me be
sure to like and share this video your
goal is to complete all three sets set
so do not stop when you're tired stop
when you're done as you progress you can
increase it to four sets increase the
repetitions to chop reps decrease the
rest time and even lift a pair of
dumbbells to make it more challenging
try not to rest more than 1 minute in
between sets and try to do this workout
two to three times weekly with other
total body workouts for best results all
the best for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to to my YouTube channel
and website do follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks
[Music]
guys